la rencontre de ce mercredi est
considérée ici comme le plus gros
événements diplomatiques de la nouvelle
administration de la maison blanche le
plus gros événement diplomatique de
l'année même selon un certain nombre
d'observateurs parce que même si la
visite en europe de joe biden a été
suivi avec attention c'est évidemment
désormais vers genève que les regards
des médias américains sont tournés dans
un certain nombre d'articles de la
presse américaine on découvre les
coulisses de la préparation de joe biden
pour cet événement joe biden qui est
venu accompagné d'un certain nombre de
ses conseillers ainsi que de son
secrétaire d'état anthony blinken afin
de préparer cet entretien il faut noter
que la plupart des matinées qu'il a
passées en europe ont été justement
consacré à la préparation et à
travailler sur les différents dossiers
qui vont être abordés avec vladimir
poutine
la femme de john dryden dit de lui qu'il
est sûr préparé pour cet entretien avec
le président russe
joe biden qui a également profité de ces
différentes rencontres avec les
représentants européens et les
représentants des pays membres de l'otan
pour échanger avec eux sur la teneur des
discussions qu'il compte à voir avec le
président russe
mais également pour recueillir leurs
idées et leur position sur un certain
nombre de sujets évidemment pour joe
biden l'idée est de donner l'image d'un
président soutenu par ses alliés
occidentaux au moment de rencontrer le
président vladimir poutine mais toute
cette préparation n'a pas empêché un
premier couac joe biden s'était dans un
premier temps dit ouvert à la
possibilité d'un échange de criminels
avec la russie dans le cadre d'un
procédé d'extradition il a ensuite été
corrigé par la maison blanche notamment
par jake sullivan qui est revenu sur
cette idée pour modérer la teneur a
expliqué que la phrase du président
américain avait été en quelque sorte
surinterpréter concernant la forme les
médias américains explique que joe biden
espère parler directement et très
franchement à vladimir poutine joe biden
qui a lui même expliqué ce à quoi ils
s'attendaient pour cet entretien je
propose l'écouté c'était lors de la
conférence de presse après le sommet de
l'otan
il n'est pas nécessaire de le faire nous
devrions trouver quel est notre intérêt
mutuel et dans l'intérêt du monde de
coopérer et voir si nous pouvons le
faire et dans les domaines où nous ne
sommes pas d'accord
établir clairement quelles sont les
lignes rouges je les rencontre et il est
intelligent il est dur et j'ai trouvé
qu'il est comme on dit quand on jouer à
la balle un adversaire de taille
ça ne sera pas la première rencontre
entre les deux hommes puisqu'il s'était
déjà entretenu en 2011 lorsque joe biden
était vice-président des etats-unis joe
biden qui a depuis eu parfois des mots
très durs à l'égard de vladimir poutine
le qualifiant notamment deux tueurs au
mois de mars dernier dans une interview
accordée à la télévision américaine
beaucoup souligne ici la volonté
affichée de joe biden de rompre avec la
diplomatie menée par certains de ses
prédécesseurs et à commencer par donald
trump et c'est en grande partie pour
cette raison que joe biden a décidé de
ne pas participer à une conférence de
presse conjointe avec vladimir poutine
parce qu'il faut dire qu'à l'époque
donald trump avait été très critiqué
après cet exercice qui allait mener
c'était en 2018 lors de sa rencontre
avec vladimir poutine à helsinki
alors malgré toutes ces précautions joe
biden est quand même la cible d'un
certain nombre de critiques
pas vraiment de la part de la presse
américaine qui se montre plutôt clémente
envers le locataire de la maison blanche
mais certains élus républicains
reprochent à joe biden ne pas se montrer
suffisamment offensif avec la russie
c'est le cas par exemple du sénateur
républicain ted cruz qui a qualifié d'
erreur géopolitique la fin des sanctions
américaines contre le projet nord stream
2 et puis il ya certains élus
républicains qui voient dans ce sommet
une forme de récompense pour vladimir
poutine alors joe biden sera le
cinquième président américain en
exercice à rencontrer vladimir poutine
des discussions qui ont parfois été
compliqué pour certains de ses
prédécesseurs ce sera donc à coup sûr un
test grandeur nature pour le nouveau
président des états unis même si la
maison blanche explique depuis
maintenant plusieurs semaines qu'il n'y
a pas de grande annonce à attendre de ce
sommet demain à genève